[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record or
talk about what I like watching videos
online where people just like this and
then everyone's like oh no they're
trying to say something about like the
Illuminati and then you go like this
yeah or they're like you mean this or
like yo
oh it's a like this any triangle
formation and then they try to like run
with that about how that's like they're
trying to like warn us don't get too
famous cuz then don't say you're a
[ __ ] lizard Illuminati man what's up
shape I know yeah I mean do it well just
go like this then that's hard that's
still a triangle isn't it yeah but now
it's not the pyramid nose like upside
down I want a sling is that is that bad
you know I'm a snake I think I always
forget what the tail the snake Chinese
zodiac so yeah
later in 89 yes mr. Boren singer my
cousin is he's a snake yes
my car was older than you out of 87
Charlie what's your Chinese okay tiger
is that why you have a tiger or one of
your that's cool that's cool I'm like a
pig or a lamb 9595 what are you Julia
I'm Morris nice what's bar rat oh that's
right we're the same here yeah that's a
funny one right a rat like everybody
gets to be these dope as animals and
[ __ ] we got rat it's supposed to be the
smartest one I know cuz we save you know
the the hole why are you
to the rat cuz the rat like rode on the
pig or the horse or what alright so they
had to work good cow it's the cow how
many the Chinese story or was it the cow
what comes out for them why was it the
cop
yes it jumped and it jumped in the cows
ear I think at the last second I was on
the last second it went we got first
place I need the last second doing is
correct but I don't think it's from the
ear thanks for the pattern you told me
the Chinese very time I don't really on
the hair that's not gelling with 12
animals though they were all we got the
snake we got the cow we got the pig we
got the horse we had that we had this
tortoise hair turn it that one thank you
we have a lamb we have the monkey yeah
and a hawk you have the rooster and then
with that twelve I think so whatever
there's the dog oh there's a dog yeah
and they were all I know cat okay where
were they going Tiger to have a banquet
with the God okay they were gone is that
real did you make that up no I think
that's real okay so they're going to see
God and then the rat just wrote on the
cow and it's gonna get tired and then
going it was the last the last place cuz
then there that means they're the
dumbest how come the Chinese are telling
a story Chinese letters and the Chinese
that's true Japanese people are
impersonating Chinese people though the
III only kind of like I feel like I only
know partially of the story because of
this anime called Fruits Basket and it's
like basically generally around the
story of the zodiac fruit basket is also
a derogatory term to call the homosexual
community fruit basket in Japan no in
America oh yeah I don't think they fruit
basket in Japan oh yeah are you Chinese
or Taiwanese or is that the same thing
Oh me that the political what do you
what I want to know
you're like oh I'm Taiwanese in another
day but I'm Chinese okay so to me this
is my take on it so don't start an all
wars out there my take on it for myself
is I think I'm Chinese to me it's by
blood I think Taiwanese is just
culturally it's almost like saying I'm
candy so I like to blow my boogers and
yell at my parents that's like a culture
part of it right but I think for me I
like all other Chinese whether it can be
sighs whatever I think you're Chinese
first and then you identify with the
culture at how or I'm sure born there
and you know like yet there's a
nationality part of it were you I was
born there but I'm not identified as
that part I'm identifying as a cultural
because I grew up in my mom so my mom's
culture my dad's culture Malaya
different it's all like my my hair just
tell me Chinese are Tony's my mom's
Tony's okay yeah yeah so are you still
there's no Annie's
native Taiwanese that's different from
Chinese Taiwanese yeah it's kind of like
Hawaii you got the locals and you have
the Native Hawaiians and in Taiwan you
have the local Chinese and any of the
native counties and then the the the
Taiwan government came after World War
two when China had a political unrest so
the Nationalists led by the Chiang
kai-shek and in the Communists led by
mr. mouth they got into a big fight and
then mr. Mao kicked out Chiang kai-shek
in the Nationalists and then they went
to Taiwan and then they said we're gonna
shell out here for a minute but
technically under world law they're
still under China but they want to be
recognized as their own nation but a lot
of countries don't recognize Taiwan as
their own nation outside of America and
China tries to block that to not get to
matters of them it's because China
claims Taiwan as their place so the
concept is right imagine if the
Democrats and Republicans just had a
huge fight right now right and in the
Republicans go to Hawaii and then they
take it over Porto Rico or any Island
and then they stay there for a minute
and then we never we're still part of
America but then like they claim a why
and they say we're gonna be a separate
country and then yeah so right now China
is ran by one party which is the
Communist
party right it's called the CCP or
whatever and then Taiwan traditionally
was the National List party but now they
have all these different groups within
Taiwan yeah so that's kind of like the
story behind it but then ethnically I
think there's a lot of Chinese descent
in Taiwan yeah ethnically I think all
the Chinese although whatever people
that identifies citron whatever
everyone's just Chinese and politically
it's different but culturally there
there's just a lot of differences yes
it's kind of like Hong Kong in China
right so Hong Kong they're Chinese
people but then they were a British
colony for the last 100 plus years and
then that's why they are used to doing
things like the West with like the way
that we have court the way we have laws
and the way that we deal with like
freedom and whatever right and then
China is gonna come over and be like
we're gonna do it our way the Communist
way and they're like [ __ ] no man we
won't do it the Hong Kong way and that's
what's happening yeah there's a lot of
fights right now with them yeah big time
well it's more like what had just
happened was there was a lot of fights
for the last of years so and then a you
know just before I think that
anniversary of when the 20 anniversary
something like that when a Hong Kong was
technically free from British whatever
that arrangement was they had just
passed some sort of like law that makes
it so people can't speak out against the
Communist Party and they were there like
not talking
yeah and acted like military force
pretty much like on the ground in Hong
Kong to pretty much arrest anybody who
like speaks out against the Communist
Party essentially so now it's like
people aren't fighting but like they're
just like living in fear in Hong Kong
apparently yeah it's so crazy that
excuse he's family has I mean they're
from Hong Kong and so even like his aunt
had to go get treated for like a panic
attack and stuff cause it's getting
insane over there that's what they're
dealing with
yeah and China has has it has people
that they pay $0.50 a day to come in to
our comments and talk [ __ ] oh yeah yeah
and then they say trying to so great are
you serious yeah dude anytime there's a
China top
being like there's a [ __ ] ton of it's
called the 50-cent army and then they'll
be on anywhere from Instagram to like
whatever and then they just come in and
they [ __ ] say great [ __ ] and they're
like you guys don't know the real China
but there's also people there that grow
up under communist rule and they can't
separate the difference between the
Communist Party which is a political
party and the identity of the of the
people there so then when you criticize
the Communist Party it's almost like
you're criticizing Chinese people so
they don't get the difference because
the people that were born there after
the Revolution they see it as one thing
yeah whereas like a lot of our Chinese
friends they came here as refugees to
escape communism and all that stuff and
so they don't they realize it's not the
same thing like there's like there's one
thing to be Chinese and another thing to
be a communist yeah do you think like
those people that go and are paid to
type hella would they start like getting
like ham problems from typing so long I
don't know they might be like some cream
or like maybe they use BOTS dude or like
some like CVD like I would think that if
I worked at a trow farm and I was like
in pain like I found this one thing this
video is brought to you by fields it's
really amazing like lately I've been
getting like some eczema right and and I
just needed something to like chill me
out cuz I've been itching all day and
this doesn't really it's not really for
that like what this is is it's just it
helps you relax and it helps you calm
down and all that stuff that's dress
yeah but with all this stress I had to
find something and feels is a premium
CBD delivered directly to your doorstep
feels naturally helps reduce stress
anxiety pain and sleeplessness and I was
having a lot of sleep problems when I
had my eczema attack I was like man let
me get a few drop of this oil in my tea
and every night I would drink that and
it would like keep me to Zen you just
place a few drops of feels under your
tongue or you feel I mean for me I did
it in my tea but you could feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about CBD is that finding your
right dose is important and everyone's
dose is different so we've room to
experiment over the course of a week or
so
you may need to take more or less to get
the effects you're after and if you're
new to CVD fields offers a free CVD
hotline to help guide your personal
experience don't take it from me take it
from them so feels works naturally to
help you feel better
there's no hi hangover or addiction join
the fields community to get fields
delivered to your door every month
you'll save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel at any time so
become a member today by going to feels
dot-com / off the record and you'll get
50% off your first order with free
shipping that's Fe ALS calm /
off-the-record become a member and get
50% automatically taken off your first
order with free shipping feels calm / o
FF th ER e SI e ar e Co Rd yeah yeah um
you know that Russia has TRO farms -
yeah yeah all of these guys they have
dresser yeah and then I heard this from
my political science teacher in like
2004 and he says the next World War 3 is
gonna be fought online and I was like oh
we have to do that mean we have TRO
farms we have so we have psyops right
which is psychological operations so in
our military they're also waging war on
social media in other countries too
because they know if they can cause
political unrest in those countries
it's way easier to wage war if people
aren't looking in the right direction if
they're fighting each other kinda like
how we're doing right now you know heard
that's what we did at the Arab Spring
you know the Arab Spring
no the Arab Spring Arab side water
delicious that would have been no it's
like all these countries that were in
the Arabian Peninsula that were taking
over their dictators and like
revolutionising that was the Arab Spring
I wish it was more like is there any
like Dance beef drama you guys had I
battle it out what do you mean specific
yeah what happens in a day in the
eighties like say like guys like
or they said some [ __ ] you guys like
Meetup and you guys like see who's
actually a better crew in the middle
that night
that's not like you guys hug it out
after that side no like one guy gets
executed after I think that's no I think
that's more well I think that's really
why the dance community even exists like
that work super kill us off by the way
like the whole idea of like battling
right is is because you don't have to
fight mmm you know anything you piss me
off my dance battle you know once we're
done it's like a man cuz they got they
got yeah but if it's like if it's like
what's that one
the krumping that looks so aggressive
but they still don't touch you
oh yeah but like break that and carping
they do yet breakdancing looks
aggressive sometimes and then they do
funny things like they Pat's their
opponents I've seen that one have you
ever done like this boom against how
that you grab his chest and plot his
heart and then you take a bite of my
favorite those are the real inspirations
is why I started dancing yeah absolutely
what's your style my style my style only
like imagine like you like unzipping an
invisible pant and then you pull out a
giant penis and then you show how long
it well it's a long one then you bend it
whoa people don't know how to battle you
cuz you're like he just sucked his own
imaginary game that's next level that
psychological walk out of that you win
oh my drop literally good work I hope it
works though - speaking of that CBD that
would be dope though if it was like you
guys settle all of your issues this way
you're the world everyone you got it -
so like everyone met like it was a
beaded music video don't be huge imagine
like as a country it's like I'm beef
with your country so we're gonna send
our best dancer that'll be so sick yeah
and then whoever wins just that's it
that's just policy from that moment I
wash I didn't see that episode we had
the big head supporting everybody I did
see that episode where yeah like a but
dog thing and it was like he would [ __ ]
it every single day like crazy and then
they had a baby the robot you know robot
yeah all right okay whoa that sounded
crazy I thought you said abut dog I
thought it was like a pet it was a robot
it was like uh it was literally made for
that dog thing but was able to have
babies
yeah those like the water was made for
it's like basically get human calm
irrelevant we're supposed to have dance
champions that represent countries and
governments or warfare from now that's
all point would you want to represent
America hell no no win no come on now
yes I can play first runner-up it's
different
which country who do you think has the
best no just own the [ __ ] out of
everyone the problem is I think that
once you okay first when you take a
actual dance styles and this is how I
understand stuff most people respond
well to the athleticism of like b-boys
and b-girls just seeing people like
flying that you can't people like
showmanship you want yeah once you have
somebody go on out there doing flips
spinning on their heads and then you
have another guy then he's like it just
doesn't feel as if I used to be bored
you know saying you want to see 10
backflips and then everyone goes
lettuces a it's the same reason why
b-boying is the first like dance sport
that's gonna be in the Olympics so
Korean that b-boy pocket
I think Korea will do really well Korea
will do very very well
how about animation though those are
good do you ever do interpreting dead
things interpretive dancing I like every
dance is interpretive no I mean like
like where you just have the music
playing and you just let your body do it
it sort of dances for I feel like when
you can dancing they just call you just
contra I know exactly conceptually I
know how to dance I would be curious
well he just said it's just dancing what
he does is already interpretive you
talking about lyrical thank you like
that jazz [ __ ] contemporary lyrical
weird it just like alright no they don't
lyrical there's no lyrics
but they call it lyrical because I've
been like I've been wanting to dance and
cuz I haven't done so long and how do
you have to think about dancing like
it's pretty easy you turn on music and
you move
yeah but it doesn't like not in the same
like environment like the atmosphere of
like when like a club like parties are
Oh Mexican so I literally grew up with
like parties every single weekend
although not having that in my life for
the last like 10 years I'm like oh [ __ ]
dancing parties cuz I'm just like I
haven't even like moved legs I remember
I used to dance and like dance in the
shower or dance as I'm doing my makeup
getting ready to go so I guys have
danced so much like just moving my body
is it like this dance dance like that
don't this is why you will not represent
our country in the wars I would never
want you like when you're clearly just
turn up the music I dance like every
week me too like that every day now
recently it has been a conscious effort
to dance because I realize I don't move
anymore
II was trying to feel like could you do
that and you're like I'm getting there I
know
ha moment she says hey I haven't been
yeah that's exactly what I mean like I
just realized like oh [ __ ] I don't move
anymore and then now I just play music
now that's what I have
it's a feeling I listen to music and I
tried to answer I'm just like already
feel like the cringe is no I'm not gonna
do in front of you dude dude I used to I
used to try to be worse off
I was like yeah like all my friends
would be boys Alan let me do my cousin
was and I get tired of people we had to
do that with meals what the space fence
anyone coffee grinders you could do that
or I used to be able to it you don't
like breakdance and what do you have a
spinny spin and I used to be able to be
nice mean yeah like the one like when
you're on your knees and let you do
anything your hand thingy and then the
hand thing you have the floor polishers
was a cricket I do I know I can't
contain my toll from starting to tap
gonna be that step back well cuz I can't
show you my feet right yeah better that
better that it's a any starts move in
yeah I like how that goes up it does
because that's you pull energy from the
ground and then you wait and then you
charge up and then sometimes you go from
the head the [ __ ] head the Bob in the
head and start caterpillar caterpillar
rings yep it's good Jones actually a
really good dancer a lot of dance moves
for forgot about the [ __ ] Lance I
don't even know like what people do is
they remember like things Ryan and they
put the puzzles together
I feel dude one day today one day I bug
in John all contemporary one day I wavy
one day [ __ ] more aggressive you know
every I just have like one style prove
it what is it tips that's that's that's
that's that's that's that yeah that's
like one of those do the left
with a ride in the front and a back
that's it it's a patter just gotta
wiggle your toe then we're gonna tow and
then the other one follow like that oh
you can also dance the robert miles -
children it's called transship only if
you have Integra and you gotta play it
the law echoes it's even older than that
yeah it's older than that [ __ ] is yeah
it's like the classical version of
trance
[Music]